for example I always wanted to play a
junkie in a movie we tried to get out of
video shoots it was like a slap in the
face you take it personally yeah we all
have the same vision we don't get a visa
we'll come back to Germany Tokyo hotel
are in Berlin to promote their new album
dream machine after more than 10 years
the band with Germany's most famous
twins are with a new record company this
time they did almost everything
themselves from writing the songs to
producing them as happy forgiveness they
just worked out that we did everything
ourselves because it felt right old
contracts had expired and we really just
wanted to start afresh no a partner on
members and put an event
[Music]
that's what their current single what it
sounds like a blend of electronic sounds
bass percussion and guitar and once
again frontman Bill Kaulitz sings about
love
[Music]
it's always kind of like the soundtrack
to our lives we're always hoping our
album will reach people and move them so
we'll be the soundtrack for someone else
to see how it works out
[Music]
the bar is set pretty high with over
seven million album sales Tokyo hotel
has become one of Germany's most
successful bands their last tour took
them across Europe North and South
America and back through Russia
[Music]
for years bill and Tom have been living
in Los Angeles with their dogs bass
player Georg and drummer Gustav live in
their hometown Magdeburg in eastern
Germany so how do they produce albums
living so far apart is a div staying
constant touch and exchange ideas we all
have the same creative vision when we
all stand behind it completely denial of
further hindered looks incredibly
difficult but we're always on the road
anyway meeting each other all around the
world just a matter of catching a flight
and you get together again
took your hotel light to polarize in
2015 when they released their feel of
all video Bill Kaulitz played a junkie
who works the streets as a prostitute
so what's it meant to provoke people
it's more like a way I can develop my
own abilities for example I always
wanted to play a junkie in a movie I
like the dark and villainous roles I
hadn't seen any films like that and
thought I'd shoot one ourselves it's not
like we said let's do the video and see
if everyone's really shocked
what has shocked Bill and Tom of the
political changes taking place in the
United States since Donald Trump became
president the annotation of course we
feel that we stand for certain things
with the lyrics we ride and when Trump
was elected bill for instance felt as if
it were an attack on him personally
like a slap in the face you take it
personally and I think politics is
personal everyone has the right to an
opinion
[Music]
in something new the first single off
their new album Tokyo hotel reintroduced
themselves as a band so many fans were
surprised that bill was the only one to
appear in the video
we don't put such intense thought we're
always trying to weasel out of video
shoots so I was glad to hear that bill
would do the next video by himself
they'll be spending the next few months
together again Tokyo hotel launched
their European tour on March 12
[Music]